although this program is made in 1986
the information and perspectives are
still unique
secretary schultz
said a few months ago that 79 americans
had been killed in tourist incidents
overseas
last year
there was a new york times article about
10 days ago
that said the figure was 23 americans
now
these things are dramatic blowing up an
airport hijacking a plane they catch the
media attention but 23 americans if
that's the accurate figure
is one-fourth the number of americans
who are struck by lightning
it's uh 132 000 the number of americans
that die from smoking related illnesses
each year it's where autumn will go one
two two thousand the number that are
killed by drunken driving on our
highways
so let's keep this thing in perspective
it's still safer
to to fly to europe on vacation than it
is to drive in your car to the rocky
mountains on vacation
and and when you you know when you begin
to add the contras and savimbi and then
a few others around the world that
president reagan supports to the list
you have to come a person from mars an
objective observer would have to
conclude
that president reagan is a far greater
terrorist than gaddafi
but the reagan administration has to be
the most astute at playing presidential
politics of anyone in 50 years if not
ever
they plan these things out they
orchestrate them
and and they have an objective in mind
the cia consists of people who are hired
screened
funded brought in from the best and the
brightest of society
with an ethic of of activity
of aggression if you will
their thing is running covert actions
their thing is also gathering
intelligence but that's frankly boring
and these are lively people
now they want to do their thing gaddafi
himself supposedly ordered the bombing
of this disco in west berlin and then we
had cables to prove it
there's a whole wing of the cia
that functions to fabricate documents
it's the easiest thing in the world it
would be absolute child's play to
produce such a cable back and forth and
would they submit it to the senate we
had was it leahy that was saying that it
was incontrovertible evidence
uh would they you know use the senate
and
you know
john stockwell was in the cia for over
13 years
he knows a lot about terrorism
and shares his insights with us tonight
on alternative
views
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this program is a good example of the
perspectives which the tv networks
ignore we're pleased once again to have
john stockwell with us on alternative
views and today john is going to talk
about the us bombing of libya and of how
these actions fit into american foreign
policy and to discuss with us the whole
issue of state terrorism and terrorism
from his perspective john was a member
of the cia for over 13 years he was the
head of the angola operation and can
give us some insight into some of the
behind the
maneuverings in terms of u.s foreign
policy against libya and to make sense
of some of the issues involved in the
most recent u.s foreign policy maneuvers
so welcome to alternative views john
can you start off by just talking about
how the libyan bombing fits into the
contours of u.s foreign policy in the
reagan era
well i think it's completely consistent
it was quite predictable
reagan came into office targeting libya
and qadhafi in 1981 they orchestrated a
big
a rush of anger
on the part of the american people
against gaddafi on libya the hit squad
the hit squad and then the newsweek
cover you know the most dangerous man in
the world with guy with an ugly qaddafi
picture on it and
and uh
it turned out that the u.s had
engineered uh
a hit on qaddafi's life
the hit squad story came out in late
november i believe jack anderson broke
it at first and then later he retracted
it and said oh now 1981.
getting into about the 10th
approximately i forget the exact dates
of december
president reagan ordered americans are
advised americans to get out of libya
and said the passport was no longer good
for traveling to libya
and then five days later
there was an attempt on gaddafi's life
uh conveniently our fleet was standing
by if there had been if it had been
successful
the libyan people would certainly have
taken to the streets and then reagan
could have claimed
as he did in grenada that american lives
were in danger and we could have gone in
and and put in a government of the us
choice
what happened was that gaddafi was
wounded slightly on the cheek
and he was not killed and the people
didn't take to the streets and the thing
fizzled as he was now this before or
after the hit squad
uh the hip squad was part of the
orchestration i see okay as they had
built up through the entire year with
reagan confronting gaddafi and focusing
attention on him
and the media cooperating and focusing
attention on him
then that throughout the summer
throughout the fall then in november the
hit squad story was was surfaced through
jack anderson getting it from his
intelligence sources
uh and later retracting and saying he
was head once again there were no it was
that gaddafi had sent a hit squad to the
u.s to assassinate reagan hit squads
where they didn't actually specify
reagan but the squads were supposedly
tracking down
top u.s leaders and the inference was
that it was reagan
or and others and i went on television
then i think with alternative views but
also with other
television programs pointing out that it
clearly was a fraud
and the reason you could tell is if
there were really hit squads in the u.s
tracking down our president and top
leaders
the whole national security police
apparatus would be going bananas
i mean literally there would be the
national guard in every airport and
police with you know everywhere and none
of this was happening the airports and
everything were absolutely normal the
capital was normal everything was normal
and so clearly it wasn't true clearly
the administration didn't believe it and
it made the fbi look bad because if
there were these hit squads what was the
fbi doing what was the fbi doing about
it clearly they they did not believe it
and uh and and sure enough like i say
the retraction but
that story was leaked in november to to
work up the final
eruption of of paranoia and hostility to
gaddafi and justification for the the
the invasion that would have occurred on
about the 19th about a month later
and uh it fizzled partly because he
wasn't killed and the trigger didn't
work
and then about that time it also became
apparent there were no no hit squads
tracking down our leaders
so
they had to back off from libya for a
while they did grenada in between they
beat the
the sandinista drum almost to death
but uh and they've come you know back
and forth against the soviet union the
evil empire uh gaddafi is absolutely
essential to reagan to continue his his
cowboy
activities galloping around on the on
the big horse you know gunning down evil
forces here and there
if it were not gaddafi if qaddafi didn't
exist they would have to find someone
else
but he's very convenient to them and
he's a perfect ploy i mean he says all
these outrageous things he sets himself
up he plays into their hands he he
sasses the big cowboy continuously and
and uh this is very this is an affront
to uh president reagan but it's the kind
of a front that he can play off of
because all the american people
virtually all
uh will support it
and of course the reagan administration
from the outset has indicated that
terrorism would be
uh one of its great causes
and it's been working on this thing
continuously uh working the media uh
working the the the the american people
up to focus on terrorism
and the basic measure
uh that you can you can use i think to
to determine how political this is as
opposed to how valid it is
is just you know which nobody has done
in the new york times or anywhere well
there was one article that did come
close
uh to pointing out that i mean nobody
will say terrorism is not an issue at
all
uh not even myself i fly on planes
internationally and i i sometimes think
well you know i hope there's not a bomb
in the belly
and i go through airports like rome and
london and elsewhere
but
secretary schultz
said a few months ago that 79 americans
had been killed in terrorist incidents
overseas
last year
there was a new york times article about
10 days ago
that said the figure was 23 americans
now
these things are dramatic blowing up an
airport hijacking a plane they catch the
media attention but 23 americans if
that's the accurate figure is one-fourth
the number of americans who were struck
by lightning
it's uh 132 000 the number of americans
that die from smoking related illnesses
each year it's autumn
one two two thousand the number that are
killed by drunken driving on our
highways
so let's keep this thing in perspective
it's still safer
to to fly to europe on vacation than it
is to drive in your car to the rocky
mountains on vacation driving is more
dangerous than you know then the
terrorist riddled airways
okay with that
simple fact
uh then you you take all of this
tremendous furore and justifications by
reagan for bombing an assault on
countries and whatnot
and you begin to say wait a minute you
know that we're kind of being had not
that i wouldn't want terrorism to go
away i would i would be delighted if it
didn't i didn't have to worry about it
at all but i'm much more likely to have
my car crack up driving back and forth
between elgin and austin
uh and then you go a step further and
say
there seems to be terrorism and then
terrorism are good terrorists and bad
terrorists our terrorists and their
terrorists our terrorists and their
terrorists except you know for the
semantical purposes since we don't want
to admit that we would be terrorists
we call ours freedom fighters
but
remember in january early february of
this year president reagan hosted jonas
savimbi at the white house and made a
big deal out of sponsoring this man and
he has proceeded to give him money and
arms
including ground to air missiles
and during that same week
jonathan b was on television advocating
terrorist attacks on gulf oil
installations in angola now gulf oil you
know
it's an american corporation
and those installations were built up in
part by 200 million dollar ex-im bank
loan that president reagan himself had
approved in 1982.
now
obviously jonas savimbi is a good
terrorist
now he has not killed
you know on the international scene he
hasn't blown up airports in in the in
the mediterranean killed a lot of his
own people
20 000 angolans
according to the red cross are are now
walking around maine missing arms or
legs because of saving these terrorist
activities i also read i think it was in
the guardian where there's a large food
shortage in angola now
partly or perhaps mainly because sabimbi
and his rolling bands put
booby traps and land mines out in the
fields where the farmers work and so
they're blowing up a lot of farmers and
clearly the bread basket of angola is is
being
done done done in the people can't work
it
then you move on to the to the
nicaraguan terrorists contras whom
president reagan you know he makes that
okay by calling them freedom fighters
now
these contras killed
several hundred people last year i mean
we're not talking about 23 or 79 several
hundred people
they uh
their killings i mean clearly there's
terrorism and terrorism in the
mediterranean these americans were shot
or are blown up in a bomb here or there
in nicaragua these contrasts go into a
village and haul people out and mutilate
them
gang-raped mothers with their children
forced to watch and slash off their
breasts before they kill them
now clearly both being you know ultimate
criminal activities but the one
which president reagan supports is
clearly far more highness than the other
one and and when you you know when you
begin to add the contras and savimbi and
then a few others around the world that
president reagan supports to the list
uh you have to come a person from mars
an objective observer would have to
conclude
that president reagan is a far greater
terrorist than gaddafi in fact let's
focus now on gaddafi who reagan claims
is a major supporter of world terrorism
he introduces the concept of state
terrorism terrorism supported by an
official government what is the evidence
for this is qaddafi one of the
worst state terrorists or supporter of
terrorism in the world well i i just
made a case that the united states
supports a lot more state-supported
terrorism in the united states is a much
bigger problem to the world
than whatever qadhafi does now qaddafi
does provide a haven
for some terrorist organizations the plo
various branches of the plo whom other
people call freedom fighters whom other
people call freedom fighters yes
there are terrorist training facilities
in libya
we have some rather remarkable insights
into these things if you'll drop back to
about 1978 and 79
and 80 the ed wilson trials the renegade
ci
paramilitary arms expert arms dealer
turned arms dealer
was actually selling remember he sent
the 80 barrels of of uh marked drilling
mud to libya that were full of tourist
devices
he had the support of top ci managers in
this thing they facilitated the licenses
for him to do this in addition to which
there they they uh
there was actually on on major
television i believe cbs interviews with
special forces
uh sergeants who were given leaves of
absence to go to libya and train at
their china lake training facility and
wilson was involved in setting that up
so we have evidence some detailed
evidence of libyan training facilities
for terrorists because we were
supporting them in 1978 and 79 and 80.
and now the media are saying that
wilson was just a renegade
and uh my goodness the cia and the the
u.s state department all really just
kind of dropped the ball they overlooked
and weren't aware of what was happening
i find that a bit incredulous well ted
shackley uh ci high official
he tried to deny at first remember the
justice department considered
indicting him
and he tried to deny it first that he
had any involvement whatsoever and then
documents were produced that had his
name on them that showed that he had
been aware of these activities and then
the cia had said this was not a ci
operation wilson in his defense said it
was and hence the documents were made
public
uh shaklee
his ultimate defense was that it was an
intelligence operation
so therefore he couldn't be prosecuted
for it but it was not an official
operation it was a
a vest pocket operation one that he
would just keep quietly himself and not
put into the formal
you know
filing system of the ci for the normal
approvals meanwhile there were millions
of dollars going into different people's
bank accounts around the world
clearly if special forces sergeants are
given leave to go to libya for a month
for training purposes uh somebody who
has the the authority to grant
full-time military personnel leave was
involved
now what do you think the reason there
must have been strategic very
machiavellian reasons for this i saw one
report where
it was a kind of a joint israeli u.s
operation where
whereby they had to they wanted to set
up qaddafi to be the center for
training and equipping terrorists
because
israel's foreign policy is based upon
having to fight terrorism
and without terrorists and terrorism
around then it would be difficult for is
israel to continue to do what they do in
their area
and so they had not only to create a
large pool of well-equipped terrorists
but they also then had to set up gaddafi
as the target that they could use to
then
rally american support around later and
well do what they're doing now is
does that sound reasonable or is it all
too pat
well it's a it's a little pat but i
would suggest what you get into in a
situation that complex and and
apparently contradictory is a
multiplicity of of reasons and reasoning
wilson was making a lot of money
what was shaklee's motive for being
involved who knows
only he would know if he made money from
it if he has a bank account somewhere
from it or if it was something else
altogether then there would be other
people who would be involved who might
not stop it
because i might sort of permitted you
know benign tolerance permit it to
happen for the reason you suggest saying
hey it's really not a bad thing
if libya becomes a big terrorist
training facility because we play off of
that cia activities are justified
israel's foreign policy part of it is
justified but now a major element of
united states foreign policy is
justified because of qaddafi's
alleged leadership
and terrorist activities now
the major media
mentioned
after the bombings pointed out that
libya is not considered to be the major
source of international state terrorism
um syria for example iran
lead and lebanon
a lead
the reason that reagan insists on
targeting libya is because it's one he's
more vocal and offensive
and two i mean the syrian leader is
fairly cool by comparison
and two libya is well exposed it's way
out here and and kind of you know in the
mediterranean where we can get at it
syria is well back inside bordering on
the soviet union
uh with soviet military treaties with
soviet military treaties and alliances
and so uh it it doesn't it's it's a
bucket of worms to try to bomb and
attack lib uh syria although we did
shell it a few years ago but
not not heavy attacks on it we're not
going to take on syria in a war or an
invasion
but this is a definite possibility with
libya that they will what has reagan
accomplished by bombing libya
the contra aid thing he pushed that for
three months and during that period of
time all of that
space in the media
all of the energy from the peaceniks
around the world all of us fighting to
stop the contra aid all of that with
space and energy taken away
from the deficit
from the trade deficit
from the fact that president reagan has
no intention whatsoever of matching
gorbachev's offers to stop testing and
to roll back the nuclear arms race he
played his peace card last year and had
a lot of fun with it but it's not in his
policies or his ideology to really roll
back the arms race if he keeps on
meeting with gorbachev and building good
relations you'll have a cooling of world
tensions
in which case you withdraw the
justification for his big arms budgets
now
all of the space that was devoted to the
contra thing was space that was not
devoted to the failures of reaganomics
and to his insistence on on on
continuing the arms race now the contra
aid thing is defeated
stopped at least temporarily and
probably permanently
and do we get a breather no he's bombing
libya
so he's going to the big western summit
conference in tokyo
where the media would have been focusing
on the fact that we have huge trade
deficits which he can't brow beat these
other countries into giving us back
money
and not to mention the deficit here not
to mention economic problems here the
stagnation that does affect a large
portion of the american
public
instead of having people writing boring
articles making him look bad on these
dull issues
that relate to failures of his
administration he has the media talking
completely but not only the media our
allies talking about terrorism
and it's worked he's gotten our allies
in europe who were not behind us in the
bombing of libya to realize that hey
this is fun it works the media can get
behind us on it people's blood pressure
rises and so now all of these countries
in the commonwealth and europe are
backing us up now and ostracizing libya
and coming up with harsh penalties on
terrorism and all of them as well
ignoring the economic problems which
they are not solving and we're not
solving interesting john did you see in
the new york times it was about three or
four days before the attack on
libya which tom wicker had a
article or
commentary
which was
very well thought out very rational
about terrorism
and he said it's absurd for reagan
to
single out not only single at libya but
anybody else
as the control center for terrorism and
it's absurd to think that
regular armed intervention which came a
few days later would be effective he was
saying that the
for one thing there are so many
different terrorist groups
operating independently of each other
that it's just impossible for one place
or one country one person to control
and then secondly
he said that
nobody has
bothered to look at the root cause of
the terrorist activity and that is the
palestinian situation if you
solve the palestinian situation find a
place for the palestinians to live or
have israel give the palestinians
a
land and equal share of the goodies in
israel
well then the there won't be any reason
for terrorism anymore
for a part of of the mediterranean
terrorism mind you
uh the center for defense information
count 60 wars being fought in the world
today
and uh in which in which they estimate 5
million people will be killed in these
wars and of course more will rise up to
replace them
the the the palestinian situation is a
large source of energy into terrorism uh
but terrorist acts committed by israel
and by the palestinians and this dates
back to the 40s even into the 30s where
they fought a bloody war
it was brutal on both sides and israel
the jews won
and now the palestinians are displaced
and and the situation continues and this
is something that president reagan
occasionally makes uh an honest remark
about pointing out that until the
palestinian problem is solved
there won't be a real solution to
terrorism but don't forget
the other 59
wars being fought around the world
all of which spawning terrorism
uh sri lanka for example yeah i mean
there are places in the world that that
never or barely make our attention
thousands of people slaughtered in in
brutal terrorist acts we find the cia
and the israeli secret police mossad
involved in so many of these and the one
in sri lanka
the tamil
dissidents are supposedly being assisted
by the israeli secret police well i had
other places also i hadn't read that
connection but the cia has been reported
to be and one of its big covert actions
is there god knows well they're working
together there right why well that would
undoubtedly figure why the ci would find
a necessity
to spend u.s taxpayers dollars
to arm and provide
energy to one side of the
sri lanka
brutal
confrontation
boggles the mind and particularly on the
side of the tom mills who are in a
minority and and have very little of any
chance of winning what is the mentality
of the cia anyway why do they is it just
some kind of fun game or is it
bureaucratic aggrandizement
it's the function
lust
it's uh
it's it's human organisms i've thought
about this a lot and even tried to write
about it some
human organizations
like to do they they assume a
personality of their own and they like
to do their thing
the irs likes to collect taxes
you know
musicians like to make music the the
musical group may play volleyball on the
side but what you know they they like to
there's there's a sense of fulfillment
by playing music
the cia consists of people who are hired
screened
funded brought in from the best and the
brightest of society
with an ethic of of activity
of aggression if you will their thing is
running covert actions their thing is
also gathering intelligence but that's
frankly boring and these are lively
people
now they want to do their thing they
instinctively look for rationales as to
why they should do their thing in any
corner of the world if you brought them
into austin texas they would look for
you know well our thing is covert action
what covert action could we run here so
the cia really needs terrorism to have a
legitimation for their activities they
need an enemy that they can strike out
on and if they don't have one well
they'll create it
and many many times they have run bloody
operations
simply calling them counter-terrorist
operations
the one in bolivia the phoenix operation
in vietnam you just call it
counter-terrorism and you've got a carte
blanche to go in there and brutalize
people remember in 1974
when the ci was being broken down by the
church committee investigations uh the
the the great revelations of covert
action
uh right after the vietnam war we were
the nation was beginning to face what
the ci had been doing
and uh the hughes-ryan amendment was
passed
curtailing uh or at least trying to
inhibit or at least to formalize
uh ci covert action
it provided that in any case of covert
action the president would have to
advise the congress the congressional
committees not everybody but the
congressional committees
of a finding that it was necessary to
undertake a covert action and then the
cia director would have to brief the six
committees of at least the the essential
elements of that covert action
now immediately
the cia president ford presented a
finding that it would be necessary
to curtail or to move against or to take
covert action against
uh
terrorism and drug smuggling wherever
they might occur in the world
and of course you know there's nowhere
in the world you can't find some drugs
or some act of terrorism and the cif a
itself has been active in drug smuggling
oh well that's that's that that they
wouldn't admit before the congress i'm
sure but see you see what they did right
right there was establish another carte
blanche to do exactly what what they had
been doing anywhere in the world john
let's let's
focus on this issue of whether bombing
or the sort of actions reagan is
undertaking against libya or the cia
takes undertakes in their
counter-terrorist movements
whether this really is a way of dealing
with a so-called terrorist problem or
does this make things worse is there any
evidence that a firm military response
to terrorism we'll break it we'll
inhibit it in any way
no
this is something that i felt that the
major media has missed
nibbling around the edges of the thing
dan rather asking that question on
national television
and i hasten to add i admire dan rather
he tries
uh there there are obvious limitations
on what he can do but he seems to try
to think these things out tom wickers
editorials he's had more than one and
anthony lewis
and
ellen goodman and others say asking just
that does the does the administration
feel that this will curtail terrorism
the point is that the administration
does not want to curtail terrorism
obviously the administration knows that
if they bomb a few targets in libya they
will have a backlash
clearly that's 100 percent predictable
and one thing for all of the fact that
that
i do my own share of reagan bashing and
we're not sure because he makes so many
slip-ups and is talking and he
misspeaking all the time and getting
confused
none of us are sure how smart he is
but the reagan administration has to be
the most astute at playing presidential
politics of anyone in 50 years if not
ever
they plan these things out they
orchestrate them
and and they have an objective in mind
they orchestrated the invasion of
grenada and they got a big you know lead
for their the the election campaign
america feeling great again
uh the bombing of of libya since the
bombing of libya the the the media has
dropped off on it a little bit but if
you read carefully enough there's a um a
major killing a bombing or an
assassination of some american or some
uh official uh a friend of ours a
country that's friendly to us
uh every day since those bombings and
this was completely predictable it is
not in the reagan's administration at
least at this level to curtail
terrorism it's in their interest to heat
the pot up
what they get out of it is continuing
distraction they get this unanimity
that's that's being melded together in
europe
uh and then they're gonna get they're
setting the stage for more dramatic
action and believe me i've i've been
pointing this out since 1980
they they want a bigger show grenada was
not big enough for them the bombing of
libya was so much fun but not a big
enough show they want to orchestrate
something bigger
nicaragua
maybe libya and nicaragua
my guess is that they're they're doing a
certain amount of thinking of course
they have to play you know play things
as they happen every day but as they
orchestrate these things let me put it
this way does anybody believe
that president reagan will really be
happy to go out of office leaving the
sandinistas in power whom he has said so
many times or another cuba in this
hemisphere
and qaddafi in power
he wants at least one of those
if not both if not both i think that he
will be frustrated if he can't do both
and i think since the bombing of libya
he's probably encouraged
ellen goodman editorial yesterday or
whenever it was today yesterday
uh in in which she's pointing out that
there's a lot of people in washington
doing an awful lot of grinning and
smiling
uh this this uh that you know the
reaction to this thing well she was
talking about the the reactor in the
soviet union but just the the atmosphere
in europe
after the bombing of libya and uh the
the soviet technical problems
uh create you know where they believe
the american people will now really let
them spend money on arms it's got to
come to something my guess is that the
inside circles
in in the white house
in the administration in washington are
talking in terms of yes
i mean they wouldn't say yes we want
more terrorism in the world as a
long-term goal but they're probably
saying you bet it's gotta we gotta heat
it up so we can do libya
and at least in that part of the
mediterranean shut this stuff down
well the flip side of that also is using
terrorism as an excuse to clamp down
police state in the united states oh
absolutely that's something that's just
slipping by americans
so totally unnoticed it seems but the
laws that they are pushing
uh
cracking down on are preparing setting
the stage to crack down on on dissidents
as they call people in the united states
who don't agree with them
uh
this you know this is the reagan
revolution and people who support
terrorism
people because
they have to make that connection
between terrorism and domestic descent
and they're a sympathizer yes they've
already said that the anybody in the
peace movement or p or people in the
sanctuary movement or even anti-nuke
activists are all supporters of
terrorism terrorist sympathizers so when
they get the law passed which they
haven't too so far all the secretary of
state has to do is say that group that
person is a terrorist or a supporter or
sympathizer
then they can go ahead and put that
person in jail
and uh there's no recourse the way the
law the bill is written now there's no
recourse in court
if they get the preemptive strikes bill
but mind you they haven't gotten that
one and hopefully they want although
immediately after the bombing of libya
there was another bill you know reword
it and try again uh but mind you they've
got now dozens of laws on the books
that that are
are setting the stage all around that
big law
and uh they have these seminars the one
in in california the article you gave me
to read the cable operation cable
splicer the cable splicer which by 1979
uh when right you know coming from
reagan's days as governor in california
uh had already graduated 14 000 people
who had been trained in all of the
techniques of controlling the population
in this country and and preemptive
strikes on just regular precipitation
groups preemptive strikes on dissident
group penetrating dissident groups and
setting them up to break the law so that
they become criminal organizations
this is you know this is what president
reagan has openly called the reagan
revolution
he can't complete his revolution until
he gets
something more than the bombing of libya
or the invasion of grenada he's got to
have
he's he's got to get the nation worked
up to where he can pull off
uh nicaragua and probably libya and this
has got to be his objective in the media
are cheerleaders of this effort they're
not raising any of the critical
questions or doubts that for instance
you're raising here in fact they're
celebrating
reagan's acts against libya his acts at
the summit getting all the european
allies together finally against
terrorism and his popularity is an
all-time high
how do you see the role of the broadcast
media
i get disappointed with some the
broadcast media you know it's
entertainment
and uh these wars are entertaining
yeah and the media you know people read
they they have to they feel they have to
write in newspapers
if something is just so totally popular
and and they will justify themselves by
saying that they've thrown in an article
or a comment here that that is
contradictory but where i get
disappointed is of course you expect
george will and william buckley to come
in applauding and asking for
for more but i get disappointed with my
my friend
anthony lewis oh yeah and ellen goodman
and tom wicker when they come in
and fail to see or admit now these are
very intelligent people who've watched
this happen before
now is it possible that they are capable
of self-delusion
in the bombing of libya and the
objectives here i get in these running
debates with people like that and david
mcmichael
uh who's who's uh maintained staunchly
he's the ex-cia he's the ci analyst and
probably the the greatest intellect
of all the people that i know who are
lobbying to stop the contra aid and stop
the
uh the low-intensity warfare against uh
nicaragua
doesn't have too much experience in the
mediterranean but this guy he testified
to the royal court this guy is
truly an intellectual and very very
smart and very well informed and he's
moving in circles where he's meeting
more and more people and yet he
maintains that the objective the new
concept is low-intensity warfare and
that's what the that's what reagan plans
and that's what reagan is going to do
and they they don't want anything more
than that
and uh i you know i keep saying wait a
minute you know david's got to be twice
as smart as i am maybe five times you
know do i dare argue with him but i
think he's missing the point i think
this low-intensity warfare is in part an
instrument for setting the stage heating
up the world
and it's in part a red hearing and it's
part because the u.s population will not
stand for anything more than that at
this time
vietnam syndrome that's his argument is
that the administration knows the
american people won't stand for anything
more and so they they they have to
settle for low-intensity warfare but the
the point is that the administration
reagan doesn't like to be buffaloed by
you know the the common misperceptions
he he has stated it's his objective
to redo replay the vietnam war to show
that it could be done that the american
people do the right thing you know if
they're properly led
i don't believe
i just read it back and forth
continuously i don't believe he wants to
go out of office without having
done a war and shown how how he feels it
should be done and erase the vietnam
syndrome and apply new laws that he felt
should have been applied then which is
why one should contest
these lower level
activities is more low-intensity
activities to try to stop it before it
does
and this is what the media has not been
doing they're acting as if this is
purely justifiable how
if if we wind up with a war
certainly
nobody will will be permitted to to be
surprised
president reagan has stated so many
times what his objectives are and what
his ideology is
he makes a lot of mistakes and frankly
he lies a lot
not perhaps any more than other
presidents but he lies a lot about
things he's doing he reads his script
and his script may not be true but he's
been honest about his ideology and his
view of the world and what turns him on
action turns him on and it also turns on
the american people now remember
in the libyan bombing
70 percent of the people supported it
and said great and yet 70 percent of the
people said it won't solve the problem
of terrorism
now if he had asked the american people
before the invasion of grenada certainly
80 percent of would have said no for
heaven's sake why bother or
it's not necessary and the bombing of
libya certainly in horror 75
but if you do it
if you play the game properly and you go
through a certain form
and you have the brass to take the
initiative and do it
so that the american people don't have
the moral responsibility for what you've
done and it's exciting action 70 percent
of them will stand up and applaud just
the action of the thing great clap clap
clap clap you know we showed qaddafi
even if we didn't show him anything
isn't there also another
perhaps a psychological aspect of it too
here we constantly are
are in a state of tension
a lot of it created just by the world
itself
and trying to make ends meet and then
also being having the fans flame
constantly by reagan terrorism terrorism
they're out to get us you know we've got
to do something we have communism you
know they're just about a day and a half
from harlagen and so everybody there's
this tension horrible tension
which is released when there's some type
of military action
hey we did something and it's focused
also against a recognizable bad guy
in a familiar
script of good versus evil
the delta force movie lee marvin and
chuck norris
doing a terrorist team on an airplane
you know the sense of the american
people getting back and doing something
back at them revenge is also i think a
very primitive part of the psychology
um here and again the media creates
these scenarios where these terrorists
are doing terrible things to americans
hijacking
ships and pushing a crippled man
overboard on a wheelchair bombing
airports and so and so these are
horrible
activities well these are right exactly
so you want a response you want to get
even the question is whether gaddafi
himself
is responsible for these acts i haven't
seen one ounce of proof
that gaddafi is directly responsible for
these terrorist activities that are so
appalled people all over the world in
fact there's a lot of evidence that
most of these activities were done by
sort of renegade groups be they
palestinians jordanians syrian whatever
and there hasn't been any evidence
that i've seen that will directly link
some of these worst actions
that have everyone so appalled to uh
gaddafi now there were those supposed uh
cables well this is what i want
intercepted to get to now the proximity
proximate justification for reagan
bombing libya is that qaddafi himself
supposedly ordered the bombing of this
disco in west berlin and then we had
cables to prove it that libya
had cabled east germany and ordered some
operatives to carry out some actions and
then supposedly the next day there were
cables back to libya saying you'll be
happy with the news you see today and
then you had the news of the bombing
what was your feeling about this were
you convinced that this was
unquestionable proof
by no means ever what made you skeptical
our our government has
lied
too many times about the justification
for its actions
it goes back 200 years in the indian
wars
uh the bay of tonkin for one if you
recall in 1978
the action in the katang of the shabba
province of zaire
where
you know fidel castro and jimmy carter
were in confrontation
the carter administration was claiming
that cuba was behind the invasion
of the katangi gendarmes into the shabba
and fidel was saying absolutely not
and carter claimed to have proof
and so a bunch of congressmen called his
bluff
and they went in to see his proof
and remember 18 of them and they came
out afterwards and they all said
it didn't prove a blessed thing
there's a whole wing of the cia
that functions to fabricate documents
it's the easiest thing in the world it
would be absolute child's play to
produce such a cable back and forth
and would they submit it to the senate
we had was it leahy that was saying that
it was incontrovertible evidence
would they you know use the senate and
you know
take al haig's white paper that he
presented to the senate in 1981 which
proved the the soviet uh cuban plot to
take over central america remember that
paper was based on documents that had
been found a suitcase full and all of
this stuff and it named the soviet
colonel who was supposed to be running
the covert action to take over central
america and later al haig had to go back
before the senate and say yes well no
such individual in fact exists but it's
a composite of individuals who would
exist in the situation as we would like
to see it and we thought it would be
convenient to put a name on him
and and you know so he was caught out in
a con
of the senate using the senate getting
them you know if you can show them a
document like that and it's based on
documentation
and now a lot of senators and
congressmen will use that and play along
whatever their own doubts as long as
they're not going to get caught out
there are others who who who you know
might sincerely be had well no one has
questioned these cables there's been
unanimity that this is evident
i mean
no one in the major media has raised any
doubts about what were we talking about
earlier the the libyan hit teams
which was you know the orc the
justification for what was going to be a
big move against libya 1981.
and then it turned out that there were
no such hit teams the this the uh
kgb connection to the assassination of
the pope uh
another one another one absolutely
derish spiegel raised some questions
about the validity of this qadhafi
connection to the berlin disco bombing
on the grounds that this was a disco
that was inhabited by arab and third
world oh yes islamic
people and black u.s american soldiers
and gaddafi as a supporter of islamic
nationalism and someone sympathetic to
black americans who that very week
before had a lot of black journalists
in libya that he was trying to court
would not go after this kind of a target
in uh berlin reagan already had the
aircraft carriers on the way
when that bombing occurred
this had been planned for it had been
planned many months many many months
just like the
the
uh grenada invasion been planned for
what about two years actually for two
years and now they're holding
um just very recently they're holding
exercises in the caribbean again
to
work up a scenario for a nicaraguan
invasion yeah
then there's another aspect and that is
the influence of gaddafi on other
countries the sudan and chad
particularly that are friendly where the
cia and the french are involved in
trying to keep
close relations down between those two
countries
so maybe other
that's another fear of the reagan and
the cia perhaps
well it's uh
it's part of the game it's a move by
gaddafi and and you know you get into
the chess you know he moves and you move
and he moves i doubt if they're really
afraid
of anything he's going to do or
accomplish but he's now mind you
forget you know don't fall into the trap
it was a trap the liberal
progressive community made in the
vietnam war
of trying to make the nlf into good guys
beyond the point of reality uh just you
know accept the fact there are no good
guys in the world
uh except for us three examples three
oh
qaddafi you know he is a wild man he's
he has put his forces here in there
including in chad
and his interests in doing so are not
necessarily for the the benefit and
well-being of all the nice little people
in chad and he you know there is
fighting there and bombing and shelling
and whatnot
he has given he if
that does not justify you know our
bombing of tripoli
but it feeds fuel to the fire
when did he come in he came in in 1971 i
believe it was about i forget the exact
date it might have been 70. i was coming
back from africa at the time
and not getting the
international news terribly well
but by 1972 as i've uh mentioned before
they had the first task force well you
weren't part of that weren't you yeah a
minor role in it yeah and what what was
it you did and that task force
they sent me
they sent me to the mediterranean to
shop around a little bit and get to see
he was cracking down
on his own people in terms of drinking
and playing
and you know no alcohol pure islam and
uh
the the the theory was that a lot of the
libyans would pay lip service to this
uh at home
perhaps you know supporting him but they
would go somewhere to drink and play
and it might have to be outside of libya
and tunisia malta wherever
italy and so the trick would be to find
where they went to play and there you
could get at them and maybe recruit them
and so we were just assessing this
possibility and and uh
my
own
uh mission turned out to be a total
boondoggle
going to watering holes all over the
mediterranean
with an expense account
to find libyans and i didn't find a
single one that's a lot of fun one way
the cia keeps their operatives happy
there's a curious historical sidelight
on that and that is that qadhafi at one
time was seen by the united states and
the cia as anti-soviet there was a time
when the cia was actually a supporter of
gaddafi because they saw him as a
fundamentalist who was hostile to
communism and didn't want anything to do
with the soviet union and therefore
supported him at certain points in
history do you remember any stories i
recall i recall that but you you can
only take that so far it was a case
where they they have always mistrusted
gaddafi but it was a case where if he
was in fact uh
standing up to the soviet union and
opposing uh communism and you can
piggyback along you know great and
encourage him a little bit great
but the ci i don't believe at any point
have they ever written memo saying hey
great here's a here's a good guy
when you travel around the country we're
running out of time by the way
what is your feel for the people in
their reaction to reagan's
cowboy
foreign policy shoot-em-up type
scenarios
it's uh it's ambivalent and it's
dangerous
i continue to run into large audiences
packed houses that stay for four hours
in in in deep and serious discussion of
all of this
with a
high percentage of support
concern
i i get the sense that every uh person
in the country whose mind
touches on these things is concerned
with the direction we're heading
obviously there's some people who are
just as intelligent but who simply don't
care about international affairs
don't read papers
aren't mentally involved but everybody
that is is clearly concerned that the
direction this nation is heading and yet
at the same time
is going along
now other people are
not really going along some people have
flat got out you know got the brakes on
a lot of people working vigorously
enough that we did stop the contra aid
at least temporarily but apparently it
stopped
and that took an enormous effort
and that's the same energy that's deeply
concerned with the prospects of war an
invasion of nicaragua
an invasion of libya
and with the nuclear arms race
the chernobyl thing for us to turn that
as goodman was writing
to have people in washington grinning
because it's proof of uh
soviet technolo technological failures
when we've had what five our last five
space shots have
crashed not to mention three mile island
not to mention three miles
dozens of nuclear accidents how
washington could see
if if goodman is right if the washington
people
see chernobyl as encouraging
because it will create support among the
american people if they're right if the
american people read that as
encouragement for more arms then we're
more superficial
even than than i am concerned that we
are
everything about chernobyl
as particularly coupled with all the
failures that we've had
recently should have everybody deeply
concerned
writing letters to their congressman
saying
hey this technology you know
don't feed it how how long
how many decades for actually that they
fed us the fail-safe story don't worry
about it it's fail-safe now they want to
build star wars which if there's a
malfunction will blow up the world yeah
then that's really insane
this should be the death knell of star
wars
this accident as well as the
problems with the challenger and all the
space shuttles because it shows how
flawed this technology is and to entrust
the computers strategic defense with
nuclear weapons is just insane
and yet we're continuing to go forth and
build
these nuclear
whole space shield to pretend to plan to
put up a huge
um
space shield
uh that would have to be so intricate to
pinpoint all of these thousands of
rockets that would be fired and within
seconds neutralize them all
and never malfunction and yet the
software for that
could never be tested ahead of time
there wouldn't be any rehearsals for it
and of course anybody who's had anything
to do with the computer know that this
stuff malfunctions continuously the
leaders are not backing down they've got
a new head of nasa who's fixed the the
date for next july when we'll get back
on course and start shooting these
things all over space again
well let's try to stop it well thank you
john keep keep pumping keep all of your
thank you for watching alternative views
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network po box
7279
austin texas 78713
please write to us there's our address
good night